optimal room at this altitude I can run
flat out for a half mile before my hands
start shaking so now I also posted
[Music]
phonetic organism living fish over
medical facility
[Music]
so this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business current thumbnail
or any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I use them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one York Times bestseller I've
also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
com forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by headspace more than
80% of the people I have interviewed
world-class performers across the
military entertainment sports and beyond
all have some type of meditative
practice I tried for years and years and
failed miserably the key is making it
simple and you can dramatically improve
your life in just 10 minutes a day and
technology can help you this change
comes through guided meditation and
headspace is by far the most popular app
for this purpose more than 4 million
users it's meditation made simple so
what I recommend is that you take this
practice meditation which is rooted in
thousands of years of tradition
supported by thousands of scientific
studies and try it for 10 minutes a day
for 10 days that's all you need to do
you can also check out the founder and
II put it combs TED talk which has more
than 5.5 million views is last name is
PUD di c om de if you want to look that
up but otherwise download
free headspace app I have it on my phone
and begin there take ten program for ten
days of guided meditation completely
free ten minutes a day that's all it
takes you should give it a shot
headspace calm forward / Tim just go to
headspace calm forward / Tim hello boys
and girls this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show or each episode it is my
job to deconstruct a world-class
performer to tease out the habits
routines tips favorite books etc that
you can use whether that is someone like
Jamie Foxx or a chess prodigy or a
Special Operations commander and
everybody in between this episode we
have Alex Honnold I've wanted to
interview a very very long time you can
find him on facebook.com forward slash
Alex Honnold h o NN o LD he is a
professional adventurer rock climber
whose free solo that means no ropes no
partner a sense of America's biggest
cliffs have made him one of the most
recognized and followed climbers in the
world if you want to sweat profusely
from your palms you can watch videos of
Alex and I'll put them in the show notes
at 4-hour workweek comm forward slash
podcast hum is distinguished for his
uncanny ability to control fear while
scaling cliffs of dizzying heights
without a rope to protect him and we
really dig into that how he looks at
risk fear addresses both in training and
with these first ascent attempts and so
on his most celebrated achievements
include the first and only free solos of
the moonlight buttress that's a 512 D
which means super hard that's
1,200 feet in Zion National Park in Utah
and the Northwest face that's a 512
a of Half Dome 2200 feet and that is in
Yosemite in California right my backyard
beautiful spot in 2012 he achieved
Yosemite s first triple solo climbing
that means in succession the national
parks three largest faces mount Watkins
Half Dome and El Capitan alone and all
in under 24 hours he is the founder of
the hähnel Foundation an environmental
nonprofit and to this day and perhaps
one of the most fascinating aspects of
Alex he maintains a very very minimalist
dirt bag climber existence and that's
meant as a slight that is meant as a
compliment living out of his van and I
think he's done that for the last ten
years or so despite the fact that he has
big sponsors and traveling the world in
search of the next great vertical
adventure so we dig into all sorts of
things and with that further ado I would
let you hear the wide-ranging
conversation that I had with Alex
Honnold Alex welcome to the show yeah
thanks thanks Evan I have wanted to
interview you ever since I first saw
footage of you climbing because I
trained long ago at Mission Cliffs here
in San Francisco and did top roping
never have climbed outside except for
Castle Rock I don't know if you know
about Santa Cruz exactly that's where I
started the kid kind of really yeah
that's where my local area so you grew
up in Sacramento or not making that up
yeah I grew up in Sacramento and what
was your bringing like I mean if you had
to describe your childhood how would you
take a stab at it
I had just just normal suburban life you
know so I could run out of good times
good times active I almost spent a lot
of time Dean Mark Bell who's a buddy has
a gym called super training gym up there
he's one of the top ten in his weight
class of all time that is the extent of
my exposure to Sacramento's just hanging
out with him then feeling really weak
which probably would have been the
experience if I'd gone climbing with you
even in the early days what did your
parents do my parents both teachers or
professors what did they teach on the
taught language like English is a second
language in French where were your
parents born in the US or they elsewhere
yeah they were both born in the US
though mom was born to Polish immigrants
so I mean she's born in the US and she's
American and her parents were actually
born here too but they were like a
hundred percent polish like fresh off
the boat so uh how did you start
climbing and it's probably a story that
you've told a million times but how did
that begin my parents just read about a
gym opening in Sacramento and I thought
I'd like it and so they took me to a
climbing gym I mean just like you were
saying a mission cliffs like there was a
comparable jamming in Sacramento and so
I went in there when I was maybe 11 and
then just kept going all the time what
was what was the first day like you
described like I honestly have no
recollection I was like an 11 year old
and then I probably went to the gym you
know three to five times a week from
11 to 18 so it's like it all kind of
blurs under like one epic Jim sessions
did you know in the early days of going
to that gym that you had a
predisposition to it no not particularly
I mean I loved climbing and I loved
going in there and just playing all the
time and climbing as much as I could but
I was never like gifted in the way that
a lot of people are gifted rock climbers
and you know I wasn't like winning the
competition's or anything I did some
comps on and off throughout my teenage
years and I never won you know I was
never I was never super strong but I
just like loved climbing all the time
why do you think you didn't win I mean
what what people did wrong I love a
strong meaning in what capacity I got
the like the details with the so for
example I mean this is kind of getting
the nitty gritty but like that's what
good is about okay here we go
so Chris Sharma is like basically that
then the best climber in the world for
the last 20 years and he was like my
hero and I was a kid or you know you was
one of the people I watched videos of
nodes like that guy's a man so he's from
Santa Cruz he started climbing the news
14 and when he was 15 he put up a route
called necessary evil and outside of Las
Vegas and it was like the first 14c in
the country so it was the hardest route
in America and he did after one year of
climbing as a 15 year old I mean that's
like a prodigy I mean he was like
freakishly strong from the get-go
he could just always pull on really
small she had freakishly strong fingers
he'd do want our pull-ups off like
anything and you're like that guy's
gifted I was not that guy you know
actually the season I tried to do that
rudeness or evil this winter and I
totally felt about it she's like I still
couldn't do it and I was like Cottingham
hasn't come for 20 years and I like try
pretty hard you know and I still just
can't climb as well as he did after one
year well I still can't climb as hard
like I'm just not as strong as you was
after one year I mean there were plenty
of things that I'm probably better at
than he is you know it's all relative
technique and everything what would what
would some of those things be that
you're better at well it's not
necessarily but I mean not to
necessarily compare you to it was that
you're here you do that he's never done
any Alpine climbing he's never really
done any big wallowing he's probably not
super efficient logistical E and you
know but he's very very strong and I'm
just not strong like that but you know
but I do other types of climbing for
those people who are not familiar with
the world of climbing could you describe
some of the different types so the
Alpine big wall yeah so climbing is it's
pretty complicated because it ranges
to endure bouldering which is probably
the simplest thing you can possibly do
to alpine climbing you know climbing in
the Himalaya or climbing huge walls
around the world and so that involves
like ice and mixed climbing where you're
using ice tools and crampons and that
kind of gear and then you know there's
big wall climbing which is basically
climbing huge vertical rock walls where
you're on the wall for multiple days
then there's I mean they're just a ton
of categories in the bouldering so for
people who don't know that is that's
typically its no ropes unroped it's I
mean an easy way to think of it as
practice climbing right you know
basically practicing movement so you're
climbing maybe three or four meters
maybe five max you know but you're
climbing small small Heights that you're
comfortable falling off and landing on a
pad and you're basically just doing
really hard physical moves it's actually
an easy way to comparative them to the
running world between sprinting and
ultra running or something like the
spectrum of climbing ranges from short
and super intense to super super long
but obviously low intensity and I've
avoided in more of the low intensity
long-distance type of guy you know where
some people are just really strong and
you were attracted to that because of
the relative lack of strength or was
there something else that appealed to
you about that um I don't know I mean I
think it might just be one of the things
that I sort of naturally gravitated
towards the thing that suits me but I
don't know I mean I think part of it is
just that I've always loved climbing I
like doing a lot of rock climbing and so
I've been attracted to high volume I
mean I like to like take the roots in my
guidebook you know be like I want to
climb this and I thought that and so I
like to climb a lot of routes yeah so
it's just yeah I mean I just like
climbing along it's certainly clear I I
wonder what what do you think you were
going to be or would you fantasize about
becoming when you grew up when you're a
kid I mean as a kid I thought I was
going to become an engineer or something
you know I just thought I would have
some normal job and I mean when I was
growing up there really wasn't a
professional climbing scene like you
couldn't really be a professional
climber because the whole climbing
industry hadn't really taken off and
there weren't so many gyms and it was
like a different world so I never
thought that I was going to be a climber
I just thought that I'd have some random
job you know I'm going off the internet
here so that's a that's a risky business
yeah but you ended up at one point
at UC Berkeley yep planning to be an
engineer yep
what type of engineering I might applied
for civil engineering I was going yeah
why civil
I mean basically one of my uncle's was a
civil engineer how much like that's cool
and I love I liked building things and
the idea of like building bridges or
like big big projects like that I mean
it's appealing you know the idea of like
constructing something cool do you did
you collect anything as a kid or do that
was way into Legos Legos okay so no
there's like over here right so the kind
of large structures large walls I how
long did you collect the Legos for I
mean give any idea I'm not looking for
timelines here but well I don't know
when I first started getting layers but
probably when I was really small and
then up until being a teenager basically
I had a ton of Legos did you have any
any like a I'm not coup de Gras is not
the right expression here I'm looking
for your landmark pieces or anything
that you remembered I like I had friends
who built like the death star out of
Legos and that was like the pinnacle of
their Lego career no I mean I think I
had a few just epic forts and like
really cool pirate ships and things and
no but I never constructed anything that
was like the culmination of my Lego Lego
career but the thing is I think I took
almost as much pleasure in destroying
the things after we're just you know
because you create like the elaborate
city and then my sister and I would take
like a golf ball or something and just
like destroy it and be like I'll start
over it's more the process of building
it that was so fun and you have one
sibling idea yeah I have an older sister
an old visitor how much older two years
older do you talk to her much yeah we're
yeah we're good friends Rashad's fair
amount yeah what is what does she do
professionally um I don't know it's
complicated it's complicated just like
makes the world a better place
she's she she's lived in Portland since
she went to college there and she's like
be and has never owned a car he's like
old four thirsty and she basically does
outdoor participation stuff with kids
and uh it's kind of like I mean she's
basically getting like at risk it's like
a work program for at-risk youth or so I
don't know it's like a whole thing yeah
but over the years she's also been like
a middle school teacher and she's done
like you know bike programs with kids
and
all kinds of you know wholesome things
that make make the community better if
you had to pick a fixed location we're
definitely going to get to the van and
everything surrounding that story but if
you had to pick a place to park up in
the US for say five years yeah let's
just make it a five-year timeline where
would we would you pick at this point I
don't know that's a tough that's tough
but I mean the obvious choices as a
climber would be somewhere like Boulder
Colorado or say Salt Lake or Flagstaff
or any of the cities that are sort of
know or Las Vegas actually places that
are known as climbing hubs where you
have great outdoor climbing all around
them and I could see living any of those
places if I had to like say you know I
got married to somebody to live there or
something crazy even like well I could
see I could see being happy in any of
those cities though on set love Portland
too though there's no real climbing
there and it's not a great place to to
live the climate and the climate stare
will look too much rain but as far as
progressive cities that go it's like
probably my favorite city in the country
voodoo doughnuts - unless you're bombing
yeah I'm not no I've been there and I
was like I you know I didn't think was
that great I'm not the best yeah like
yeah I was a little underwhelmed yeah
could have been my blood alcohol content
at the time but do you think so I want
to talk about climbing and the ability
to climb full-time because you touch
nothing a really important point which
is when you began climbing the prospect
of becoming a professional climber just
didn't really exist right as an ocean I
mean there were a handful of
professional climbers when I started but
it was like such a small there wasn't
like a climbing industry it's really
small exactly yeah and I you have a
reputation for or you're well known for
living as and this is a term I hadn't
heard until I watched a documentary that
Vaughn canard was in dirt bag
and living as a dirt bag climber can you
describe that what does that mean first
of all and what is your version of that
well so I mean I guess that just means
somebody who is like a lifestyle climate
like somebody who just lives to climb so
it's like the full-time on the road you
know doing whatever it takes to be a
climber I guess I mean being a dirt bag
isn't is
negative thing in the climbing community
right just like all that guys committed
to the cause and I'm sure there's the
same kind of term for like the surf
community or whatever else you know
people who just like live to go mountain
biking or surfing or whatever you know
taking odd jobs and just like doing a
thing just to to be able to do their
sport as much they can and it seems I
remember years ago I chatted with Stef
Davis when I was wearing on the for our
body seems like a very semi monastic
lifestyle I mean you're really dedicated
makes me think of like the marathon
monks in Japan but instead of you know
running every day you're climbing sort
of the site internet lifestyle now you
live do you currently used to live in a
van oh yeah I mostly live in my car but
then I'm overseas long way now and then
when I'm traveling for work stuff so I
get put up in hotels or whatever but I'm
buddy I mean I'm so focused in the band
what kind of been well I just sold my
old man so I lived in the van for nine
years and that just sold at one of my
cousins because I was just kind of over
I felt like I sort out good now and so
now I have a dodge Promaster which I can
stand in which is a big big upgrade how
tellingly life I'm like 511 what have
you have you kidded out this van to be
suited to your new so I actually just
left it with a friend of mine who built
it out while I was on an expedition in
Patagonia this winter and so he just
made it nice I mean you know super nice
bed and like a kitchen and good
cabinetry and you know a refrigerator
and yeah I mean it's basically a really
small apartment it's super nice and the
coming back to the industry so are there
people who criticize the industry of
climbing sponsor influx and the reason I
bring that up is not because I'm
critical it's because I've seen for
instance in the UFC and MMA when in the
very early days it was it was really
unfeasible for people to be professional
MMA athlete and as soon as sponsors came
in and you had that sustainability the
level of athleticism and training and
competency just went completely through
the roof is it is there something
similar in climbing I mean do you feel
how do you feel about the so called
climbing industry I mean I think it I
think it's great
it I mean there is obviously criticism
and you can find stuff online from you
can always find traditionalists and
stuff we were like this isn't the way it
was when I grew up so I don't think it
should be this way we're like oh I feel
like it's corrupting the art of climbing
or whatever else you know the having
corporate money coming into the climbing
world is tainting the the artistic
experience I mean whatever I mean you
know you can find criticism for it I
think it's great I mean obviously since
I'm making a living from it and I'm able
to go climbing all the time you know I'm
very content with the whole situation
but mostly I just feel like it's sort of
a natural outgrowth I mean climbing gyms
are becoming much more popular because
people enjoy climbing you know and so if
people are into it and the industry is
making money then power to it well it
also strikes me is sort of a
self-fulfilling prophecy but a virtuous
cycle in so much as the more people see
your exploits Sharma people of that
caliber the more they're inspired to try
climbing the better the gyms do the more
classy I do not think that just was that
that might be true a little bit but um I
honestly think that part of is just
having the facilities like the more good
gyms there are in urban centers the more
people just wind up trying it with their
friends or whatever you know when you
have like a nice bouldering gym next to
a college campus like everybody tries it
because it's fun it's sociable everybody
has a good time and I feel like that
sort of like grows the sport yeah so the
supplies helps create the demand yeah I
went to some extent but I really doubt
that any particular climbing film can be
responsible for like growing the whole
industry you know it has more to do a
ton of people like go into gyms and
trying it and enjoying it and going more
often yeah I guess it it depends a lot
on a multitude of factors I mean with
not to belabor the point or the
comparison to the MMA world but like the
Ultimate Fighter was kind of the
breakthrough for them and then led to a
lot of gyms opening yeah the climbing
has never had anything quite that so
totally like I don't follow fighting it
all by have even heard of Ultimate
Fighter and I kind of stuff and so I
don't think climbing's really had that
you know they're you know like big hit
reality TV climbing show you know know
though actually there's they're having a
Pitchess that I gotta stop though which
are pretty comical what
it looks to be actual fish it's aliens
meets bouldering I like yeah oh there
was an ultimate solo thing they got like
pitched me once and I was like dude you
can't just take random people off the
street it might train them how to solo
for six weeks and then just like set
them off of a big wall it's Aikido yeah
also you may as well just have
gladiators fighting volumes in the pit
you know it's like like people would
literally die on your television show
like you don't want people dying on TV
like no no that's exactly what we want
well it's like like are you guys kidding
you know because you have to insure the
show and everything like no one's going
to make this because like half your
contestants are going to die like a
straight-up that's tell myself yeah
we'll have love some beer sometimes
talking about exploits in television but
when you are getting ready to climb
something that is going to be
challenging I'm not saying like a first
ascent or something like that but really
anything that you're expecting to be
reasonably challenging
what is your self-talk sound like what
is your do you have any sort of prep
anything you ritual ritualistically say
to yourself before you know I don't
really I don't
self talk like that but um normally if
I'm planning on doing something
challenging I spend the time sort of
visualizing what the experience will
feel like and what the individual
sections so I mean with climbing there's
a there's a component to of just
memorizing natural moves so I'll think
through the sequences and make sure that
I remember like which foot to move in
which order and like how to do
everything and then particularly if it's
the free solo or something if I'm
climbing rope lists then I'll think
through what it'll feel like to be in
certain positions because some kinds of
movements are insecure and so they're
just like kind of scarier than other
types of moves and so it's important to
me to sort of think through how about
all feel when I'm up there so that when
I'm doing it I don't suddenly be like oh
my god this is really scary you know
like I know that it's supposed to be
scary I know that's going to be the move
I know it's going to feel like and I
just do it
so you rehearse if I hear in a sense or
we have a sensation one of which I do
fear yeah and I think through you know
how Airy certain positions will feel
because sometimes you can be all spread
out with like the void below you and
you're like wow this is like quite the
quite the air around me and so it's good
to have like thought about that
basically to think through all potential
things beforehand so that when you're up
there there's no like unexpected
thing that happens you know we were
talking earlier about this this this
odd-looking fellow the white bust over
on my counter who is for those of you
who don't have a visual is Seneca the
younger which was a gift and of course
those of you who listen to that I'm
somewhat obsessed compelled to read a
lot of stoic philosophy and Marcus
Aurelius and so on but how would you
describe your if you had to take a stab
at and though this is a hard question
but you're just like general how does
your philosophy or philosophies of life
and living differ from most people I
don't know I mean I've never really
thought of any comprehensive life life
philosophy or anything you know I don't
feel like I have a particular set of
principles that it was life though I'm
you know I suppose I'm pretty
minimalistic and and you know meeting a
fairly simple life and I mean I guess
that's basically um how I live far know
what are the benefits of living simply
to you aside from the ease of travel but
I would imagine at this point you could
probably travel reasonably easily well
no I mean that's kind of it is that um
yeah just the ease of living you know
basically it just cuts away everything
except for what I want to be I mean
because my goal is basically to climb as
much as I can and that's what I enjoy
most in life is climbing into everything
else
to some extent is a distraction from
that and so you know I basically just
cut away at what I don't need so I heard
a story and this was like a friend of a
friend of a friend relaying something
they had heard we'll see where this is
yes like telephone yeah exactly so who
knows
yeah but they told this story about you
free climbing and this is a very strong
program I'm sorry yeah that's right
recently a big wall where at some point
there were some people resting I don't
know if they're in a how do you say
bivouac portal edge movie port aliza
camp thing that you're right yeah and
and you can adduct your head around the
corner like hey can I borrow some chalk
and they're like ah sure and give you
some chalk and then you're like thanks
great and just kind of like continued on
your merry way that has anything like
that happened or is that just ya know so
the
is a real story sort of with some
details okay can you can you tell Don
yeah so I was I was soloing the triple
link up in Yosemite so I wasn't free
soloing but I was climbing by myself so
I had a little bit of had a small rope
and I got it okay this is an important
distinction so yeah okay got it so solar
climbing is just climbing by yourself
yeah and resoling means that you're free
climbing and the free climbing means
using your hands in your feet and not
using gear and so if you're free soloing
it means that you're climbing with just
your hands and your feet by yourself
like no gear and no anything not it but
so in this case I was soloing so I had
gear and I was soloing the three largest
faces in Yosemite in the day so Mountain
Watkins which is like way up but one end
of the valley and I'd done that first
and then I came down and I was climbing
the notice of El Capitan through the
night and in the logistical shuffle and
the darkness whatever I forgot my chalk
bag so I basically climbed the first
thousand feet of the nose without a
chalk bag and was like which is kind of
a bummer I mean that's definitely not
ideal so the other statement and it
actually it is actually rained a bunch
today before so like the bottom pitches
which is lower angle we're like fairly
wet and I was like constant trying to
dry my hands on my shirt and it was just
all kind of scary and so I got up to
this ledge called Bowl tower which is
you know about a quarter of the way up
the wall and there were two groups
divvied on the ledge and two of the
people words like passed out in the
other two guys like cooking dinner and
so I pop over the one side of the legend
I'm like uh hey so can I borrow a chalk
bag and they were like yeah because yes
like no problem you know so what do the
guys gave you this chalk bag it was like
completely full of like fresh chalk I
was so stoked and then I took a chalk
bag and then I climbed to the top of the
route and then I left it like tied to
the tree on top I think I got it back I
met him again later and then yeah so
they got their chalk bag back like four
days later what do you have a particular
type of chalk do you like no but I mean
any chalk feels amazing when you just
climbed a thousand feet a wall while
you're wet wet what is uh what's a story
and I realize a lot of these questions
are kinda out there but what is a story
that your your family or parents like to
tell about you
oh I don't know I'll buy us some time
away think about it so the one that my
parents like tell about me is I was
completely infatuated with the
Incredible Hulk when Lou Ferrigno's
during the TV show so to run into the
into the living room when my parents had
company and ripped the cushions off of
the couch and throw them on the floor
and yell like the Hulk and run out so my
mom feels like that in some way
represents like me and my tooth Valerie
heuristic of yours yeah which I don't
know how to take but that's the stories
she likes so uh uh anything come to mind
I don't know I mean mom likes to talk
about I always clowning on everything as
a kid and how it was such a wild child
but though I honestly feel like she's
kind of like she she talks about that
more now that I am an actual
professional climber you know I feel
like had I become an engineer she would
instead focus on stories of like how I
always loved to play with blocks or do
whatever but and my whole family would
always tell stories about how I was such
a picky eater and how I'd only you know
Cheerios and bread and like whatever
just think I don't know but what do you
we were talking just during the
soundcheck about eating and I like to
talk about that for a second
what is your typical breakfast look like
generally well so I've kind of gone
through two main phases I guess I used
to always do like an egg scramble for
breakfast and now I pretty much always
do some kind of mutant concoction with
like fruit and some kind of alternative
milk stuff and like flax seed hemp parts
like random things sort of like a
wholesome usually mix and then I asked
you about lunch and would you have to
say about lunch yeah so I I rarely eat a
lunch per se I pretty much always just
snack for the several hours in the
middle of the day normally like a couple
pieces of fruit maybe some nut butter
you know it's a bar or two or something
and then I eat like a big dinner I don't
really do a pretty big breakfast in a
pretty big dinner and then just snack
throughout the rest why why no lunch
will the no lunch thing make sense when
you're up on wall for the day or if
you're like out at the cliff or it's
just like a bunch of work to you take a
real meal so I wasn't going to get to
this immediately this this early this is
early for me and I'm more like that so
but suppose that said I'm always
premature
it's like my friend when he drives we
call him a premature accelerator but
that's that's almost every story I so
this is from a friend of mine who's an
elite athlete very high level female
athlete I'll ask her main question first
actually no I'll ask the related
question first so the food real hassle
so the question was what happens if you
have to take a on the side of a
mountain meaning like so many good
pooping stories okay we could do a whole
podcast I see stories alright let's give
him preview like if it's around - but
yeah let's I mean I was wondering she
brought up I was like holy yeah
should I go straight to my most epic
dump story yes please okay
so I had two years ago I guess I was
free soloing this route called romantic
warrior and the needles which is
actually a romantic warrior yeah like
it's actually one of the most striking
granite walls like in the world this was
totally beautiful rude on this crazy
spire it's an amazing amazing route it's
something I thought about for a long
time and it's actually quite difficult
and so I was going up there to free soul
is like kind of a big thing for me and I
was way stoked and typically when you
get to the base of free so low that if
you have to poop at all like you have to
go like that you know when you're at the
base but I just like it I don't know it
just didn't quite happen and uh and so I
started climbing in that route the first
400 feet or so or like pretty moderate
train and then it goes into like some
pretty extreme terrain for the second
400 feet and uh so basically right
before I got into the real stuff I was
like oh now I really need to I was
like oh man you know basically I was
like oh it's about to get real up here
and like I know I need to poop and so I
basically hand traversed on this little
feature so the Traverse off the rigs is
really poor form - like on a route
because I see people have to climb now
so that hand Traverse meaning you're
just traveling horizontally yeah so I
sort of just like meander to the left 20
feet and this flake that I was hanging
off it was like fairly big and I had a
backpack on me with like my shoes and
some water and some food random things
that you kind of need for you know going
up a long route like that and it had
some teepee in it so I like shoved my
backpack into this lake and I just like
hung there off of it and basically just
took a poop like straight off the wall
just like while hanging and then you
know like wipe tidied up is all good and
then I put my pack bag on traverse
baguette and I pitched the route it's
like so
no I just want to really dig into this
resilience so so I'm just like
envisioning I had bats I grew up on Long
Island we'd have these bats that would
like crap off of the shingles and we'd
be like where the hell is that from then
we'd see the bat kind of perched there
so okay
what's the technique here so you you're
hanging off this flake if your backpack
shoved into it like legs straight and
straddle bugging like a like I just sort
of like I'm a semi seated crouched you
know pushing away from the wall a bit
and are you going like out of the bottom
of your shorts you pull and down pull my
shorts down just like normal like okay
yeah okay yeah I mean it's actually
totally easy I mean I'd call it a space
dump Space Jam yeah a climber would call
it like a perfect space dump it's just
like taking a dump in a free space and
it just disappears okay so what are
other challenges of climbing on big
walls outside something yeah don't let
that give the wrong idea because
normally you try to like food better
places you know preferably a toilet like
or at least like bare get properly at
the base or you know like being being
responsible about it but like from time
to time that happens you know things
have a yeah what are other what are
other issues that crop up that people
might not think of when you're doing
these clubs
well people frequently ask what do you
do if you have to pee or whatever these
they think I mean I think that people
have the wrong impression that free
soloing a big wall is just like holding
on for dear life the whole time but
they're actually all kinds of little
ledges like even allege the size of say
a pizza tray is big enough for you to
stand there comfortably no hands right
and so I mean that's an easy place so
you could take a leak you could you know
take a sip of water you can eat a little
bar and anytime I'm on a ledge say the
size is sofa cushion or something I'll
basically pop my shoes off and relax my
toes for a minute because climbing shoes
are quite tight so like your feet start
to cramp after a while I mean there's a
lot more self-care going on up there
than people might think do you carry for
that self-care do you carry any other
tools and you're like I don't know nail
clippers any particular type of like
well I'm just making supplication or
anything nothing you don't end on your
hands but no no I mean I normally just
take food water and then a pair of their
produce I can walk down afterward what
type of food you bring with you
typically I just bring you know sports
bar type will know like what's bar I'm
all and let stuff you get nailed gritty
I don't know I mean
I mean I used to be sponsored by Clif
Bar so I do like you know shop logs and
see bars I love the Z bars the little
kids Clif bars mostly because they're
kind of half size they're like a hard
calories and they basically taste like
your cookie so I can't like I always eat
them because they're just kind of
delicious but now I can kind of get more
into like nut butters and things though
the typical free solos are short enough
that you don't really need like a full
hearty meal you can kind of get by with
like a pack of shop locks or like one
little one sugary thing to just kind of
keep you going it's on like bigger
climbs like alpinism or something where
you have to take like a lot of you know
fatty you like higher calorie food so
this this is actually I will be the
first person to admit that I actually do
not know what alpinism is and but one of
the questions that came up this from
Kelly O'Shea one of my listeners is ask
Alex about his recent achievements in
alpinism what was it like as someone
who's so accomplished in one discipline
to be a beginner again another type of
climbing
can you explain what albinism is and
then how you would answer that so I open
ISM I guess is basically just climbing
bigger mountains or big snowy or icy
faces or you know granted walls that are
also covered with ice I don't know I
mean I open ism is just climbing the
things that you see in posters where
you're like whoa that looks like a big
scary mountain you know because I've
always been more of a rock climber which
is climbing like vertical dry granite
walls alpinism it's like when you do
that in more remote places and like you
hiked across a glacier you get to the
bottom of some huge icy face and then
you do all kinds of shenanigans to get
to the top but so what what mistakes did
you make if anyone first starting that
type of climbing well so basically I
mean I haven't done a lot of alpinism
and I still I can't ice climb at all
I've never led a pitcher of ice but I've
actually done a handful of things that
are considered like noteworthy Alpine a
sense now but has more to do is choosing
like the right partners because I go
with somebody who's like way more
experienced in the air just someone who
has much more of a plan and then it's
sort of about the division of labor you
know like someone who's good at one
thing and I'm obviously good at the
rock-climbing component of it so even
though I'm a total beginner with the ice
climbing with all the logistics and the
camping and I
dealing with living on a glacier all
that kind of stuff is totally new to me
but at least I know how to do the
climbing pretty well so then you know
you just find the teammate who
complements that skillset well and then
you can go on and climb all kinds of
crazy things it's an L I probably
mentioned this in the intro but just in
case I haven't for people listening I'm
sitting in my living room we are sitting
in my living room and we have a whole
likes a lynx of people surrounding us
because we're filming this now one of
the one of the people here has actually
been on the podcast before so Jimmy chin
how does your climbing differ most from
his which Jimmy Chan is predominantly a
photographer so his climbing not really
climbing is mostly just going up behind
people take pictures I'm talking to you
Joe vision no I mean but so Jimmy's and
Jimmy's addendum classically more of a
big wall climber I mean Jimmy has never
been like the best freak on like you
know I mean he's not doing one-arm
pull-ups on small edges and he's not
like climbing the hardest sport routes
but he's always been able to like get to
the top of big walls and then been able
to do that in the mountains you know
with ice and snow and bad conditions and
so he sort of the climbing that he's
been good at has been like farther along
the spectrum of you know big and badass
and the type of climbing you know
because I grew up in a climbing gym and
then sort of gradually extended to like
big rock walls you know and he sort of
started on big rock walls and then
extended into the bigger mountains who
when you were getting started just
thinking back to say the first 10 years
of climbing hell you know I'm 30 30 and
old I thought I heard your joints
creaking yeah ha ha I feel like yeah who
were some of your early mentors in
climbing I didn't have a lot of mentors
when I mean I kind of grew up in the gym
just climbing a lot so I didn't really
have mentors I mean I definitely had
people that I looked up to and people in
the climbing community that's just sort
of the typical hero where should be
style you know like Peter Croft was
really prominent solos from the
generation before me and I was like all
Peter's the man and uh you know Chris
charm obviously was was like setting all
kinds of world record type things when I
was a kid and I was just like oh he's so
amazing
and Tommy Caldwell was also a big hero
which is Nakul beacon Agata climate song
is an adult I'm just like
pretty cool still always excited to
comment on me but what if you were so
I'm going to take like 20 different
questions and hopefully wrap it into one
question and we can we can take some
time on this but if you were taking a
let's just say an athletic rope beginner
so someone who's never done any climbing
and that has a decent athletic
background right 20 25 years old and
they want to get really good at say
bouldering and you were going to kind of
lay out give them advice or train them
for like eight weeks what would you what
would happen to do what what would the
what would that look like I I don't know
I'd have to think about it a lot because
I mean particularly with bowling it's
sort of it's interesting so adults are
more prone to injury than than kids to
some a Centon especially with with
something like bouldering where it's
really heavy on fingers like basically
it's really easy to injure your fingers
in hands because all the connective
tissue and like tendons and ligaments
take a very very long time to strengthen
so I mean there's no real shortcut to to
avoiding tendon injury whereas an adult
like a 25 year old male would gain
muscle mass super fast so really quickly
they could exceed the capacity of the
tendons and basically just rip their
tendons out of their arms you know and
so it's like one of the things where I
mean if I was trying to train somebody
to be a good rock climber I would focus
on on movement and technique and
footwork and all those kinds of things
but if somebody was like in eight weeks
I have to be able to Boulder like a
certain difficulty level I'd be like
well I mean just start like training
your fingers and hope that you don't get
injured but like obviously that's not a
sustainable like if you're trying to be
a good climber that's not the way to do
it it's better to start with like the
foundation so let's talk about the the
footwork and technique then because I
believe I mean you've been to a ton of
climbing gyms I've been to mission class
I'm not a good climber I would not say
but I can also recognize but not dissect
when I see good climbing versus bad
climbing right where people are just I'm
just shaking like a leaf and using a
haul arm strength ah what what types of
advice would you give someone who want
to do it the right way but they're like
alright I just I want to focus on the
right things what should I really focus
on and obviously the right things are
movement and technique and so like how
you move over the
has nothing to do with how well you can
hold on or like how hard you pull has to
do with look you know knowing where your
center of mass is and like being able to
move your body around in the right ways
that you can stay balanced over your
feet and you can move yourself upward
with your feet how do you conserve
energy when you're climbing it was I
mean leaving out that the the pizza
sized pizza box yes I know I mean the
main ways to save energy or to keep keep
your weight on your feet which is kind
of the same thing to stay balanced over
your feet so that all as much weight as
possible is on your feet
so you're just standing and then to keep
your arms straight or to keep all your
limbs straight so that you're hanging
off your skeleton more than your muscles
because if you have your arms bent at 90
degrees like a t-rex or something then
you're like totally engaging your bicep
and your lats and you're getting tired
if you have your arms totally straight
then you're only engaging just as much
muscles you need to keep your fingers
holding on but everything else is
relaxed because you're hanging off your
bones so I want to underscore something
you said a little earlier because a lot
of sort of aggressive dudes whistle in
this podcast ah hit aggressive dude
aggressively that mean email like eight
we just felt like slap on a ton of
muscle on my arms and like biceps and
laps and go crush this bouldering wall
but you made a really important point
several one of which was that if you if
you pack on a lot of muscular strength
you can outstrip your sort of tendon
action really quickly
well Caligula is an adult I mean if you
start climbing as a kid then then you
gain muscle this is sort of the same you
know that's right yeah you're in like
hormonal nirvana the adolescent and this
is something that also got named Chris
summer coach summer underscored for me
he is the former national gymnastics
team coach for men's and he was saying
that unlike many other supports I get to
contraindicated say use anabolics in
gymnastics because all you're going to
do is end up rupturing a tendon or
ligament for the same order wins yeah I
totally fans chronic I what are you
worried about when you go to sleep at
night if anything like when you worry
before you go to bed what kind of stuff
do you worry about oh oh like that's a
quick 180 yeah this is good as well
we're that agree to keep with
on my toes that's what people scrub in
to the podcast get confused yeah I don't
want any story line that they try to
skip ahead yeah I exactly know I don't
really worry that much when I want to
sleep I mean the stuff that I get
stressed about is all like real life
stuff with you know dealing with email
and responding to calls and like you
know hustlin and I don't like doing my
taxes you know like all the stuff that
I'm just like not good at so let me ask
this is like partially me turning this
into a therapy session for my sake but I
just wait now how am I gonna lie on this
over here oh yeah that's that's usually
my second place god gas the pressure
could be just relaxed but the the the
question I like to ask is why do this
when is enough enough to fuel the
climbing meaning what do you hope to do
with the additional money you make above
and beyond what you need to sustain
climbing often because it's not at a
certain point you surpass that pretty
easily but you know you're certainly
keeping busy I am you have a number of
sponsors you're tremendously good at
what you do so what do you want to do I
mean that is interesting because and
I've you know thought about this a lot
over the years because first day the
first 5 or 7 years that I was living in
the van my overheads probably 10 to 15 K
a year and I now obviously make a lot
more than that through sponsorship and
just doing like one commercial or
something you know I can make many times
what I need to to live in the road for a
long time and so you know part of that I
mean I'm obviously saving for retirement
things like that trying to be
responsible of money but and then I've
also started foundation where I've been
giving probably a third of my income now
to to environmental nonprofit things but
yeah basically
I mean I'm - the foundation was kind of
my my response to that kind of stuff cuz
I was like I just don't need to make
more of the thing as it is actually kind
of fun to make more you know it's like
fun to do the random opportunities like
to do a commercial project or to like
give some talk to some interesting
company or you know whatever I mean it's
kind of fun to be able to hustle out
money like that but then it's like
equally fun to be able to you know use
that money for something positive which
is you know through the foundation this
is
what is the name of tonation conscious
Donald foundation easy to remember yeah
it's like kind of douchey but like it
kind of made sense I don't think it's
big shipping as you remember it just
visible the yeah
so the reason I was asking about the
what do you worry about before you go to
bed is because they're people I have
never seen so many questions about brass
balls in my life when I polled my
readers four questions for you and we've
never had an in-depth conversation but I
know a lot of people say here in Silicon
Valley or other folks who give the
appearance of being invincible if they
never worry about anything and it can be
kind of demoralizing for people who feel
like they need to be superhuman to
achieve good things and so what I always
like to ask people who are spectacular
good at what they do or dig into is like
what challenges they've had or what they
struggle with so for those people who
say like that guy's got everything
together doesn't worry about anything
I'm not like that what are some like
what what are some of the challenges
were dark periods that you've had if any
come to mind and if the answer is none
then that's that's it financially
invincible no I mean what's funny USB
just in the last two months I've had two
sort of random injuries that are like
super annoying which I hadn't really had
any kind of injuries climbing in in
years or like ever really but like last
month and in April I got a I got dropped
on a partner so I got lowered off the
end of a rope and like compression
fracture to burger in my back and I was
ultra bruised and so my hips and butt
and stuff you know my back's been really
tight I think kind of achy does that
worked out kind of okay it was two days
before I was supposed to fly to China
for a climbing expedition and so I was
like well all the travel time will sort
of be like good rest I guess and then
you know I got there and I was like
creaky old man but I actually did manage
to climb the thing that we were hoping
to do and it all kind of worked out okay
in the end but you know there's
definitely was a little touch-and-go so
I was like at first I mean when I was
going to the airport to fly to China I
couldn't even lift my duffel bags
because like my back was too sore and
everything was too too creaky and then
actually just like two days ago I took a
weird fall why should I took a totally
normal fall but I somehow tweaked my
hand in a weird way
and especially mean you can probably see
the back of my right yeah I was looking
at them yeah my right hand is like all
messed up right now
and and you know I mean there's
definitely a lot of uncertainty there
because I mean I I can't even like click
the power button on my phone without
like pretty serious pain with my right
hand right now but you know it's been
two days and it's kind of improving and
you know we'll see like and things the
forecast is rain for the next three days
so I might as well I'll have three days
to rest and then you know maybe it'll be
okay or maybe it'll be good enough that
I can Elise work towards some of my
other goals for the season and then by
the time it's recovered and say another
two weeks I'll be like ready to that you
know do some of the things I wanted em
and we'll see which is kind of how China
went I was like well you know I can at
least do all the work towards what I'm
trying to climb while I'm crippled and
then by the time it was ready by the
time I was ready to actually try to
climb the route I was like oh I'm
actually feeling good enough by now and
I was able to do it do you ever get
depressed or have you ever been
depressed yeah yeah no I think I mean I
think I kind of gravitated towards being
a somewhat depressed person I don't know
or I don't know actually
or I'm just sort of like flat into that
first part and we'll see what we come up
with so why do you say that you think I
definitely oscillate to fairly high
highs and reasonably low lows and I've
been trying to take the edge like take
the 20 top I think the top and bottom
20% off of those to make it a little
more manageable but why do you say that
you might tend towards easy I feel like
I don't have any of the highs and I kind
of go from from level to like slightly
below level of the back you know it's
all like it's all pretty flat I feel
like and just that when I don't know
when you dip does that is that triggered
by certain types of things or is it just
a cycle that comes with time um yeah
maybe it's just a cycle time it's like
sometimes you just feel useless you know
but I mean in some ways though I embrace
that as part of the process because you
kind of have to feel like a worthless
piece of poop in order to get motivated
and actually go do something that makes
you feel less useless
but then but then ultimately that still
doesn't make you feel any less useful
you just as you keep doing more so
that's perfect segue to the view the
main question from the one person who
asked what you do when you have to take
a on the side of a wall is there or
do you ever see a point where you'll
feel that you've accomplished all that
you can and climbing whereas there
always a what's next I think there's
definitely you know I can definitely see
a point where I wouldn't continue
pushing I mean there is always what's
next and climbing and um you know I mean
you can always try to improve in some
way or like go to new places or do first
a sense or I mean you know there is
always something new to be done in
climbing though I can definitely see
personally a point at which you know I'm
like okay I'm satisfied like I've done
wanting to do and you know yeah we'll
see you kind of though I will say
climbing up more than most other
professional sports has like quite a
long career span kind of because of that
because there's always more you can do
with like trips and expeditions and
first of Sensen and there's a really
creative process to it you know as I
come up with interesting challenges and
it's just sort of like do things that
nobody thought up before and so yeah I
mean you know they're professional
climbers in their 50s that are still
like getting after it like that when
when you are about to do a big climb or
just a very strenuous climbing workout
I'm sure if you do that anymore maybe
then talk about it but how do you warm
up if you do I was warm up pretty pretty
gently when I can just so just um I mean
it depends on where I am if I'm in a
climbing gym then I just warm up on a
handful of easy routes and then and then
start the harder ones later I mean for
the last month and half up and
stretching like every morning every
night because of the back thing and
because how tight my hips and and
everything feel right now so doing some
stretching and some like light exercise
to sort of warm up and then yeah when
you can't climb let's just say you're
you're on the road mm-hmm what type of
exercise do you do I mean I try to still
climb when I'm on the road I mean
there's just so many gyms and different
places that you can always do that but
if there's absolutely nothing then maybe
I'll run or I'll go high
gaynor it kind of depends on what
opportunities there I mean I'd rather go
mountain biking than than other things
or I'd rather go skiing it's available
but I mean as long as I'm getting some
kind of assess I mean even like stand-up
paddleboarding or something like well at
least I did something today you know a
lot of recreational climbers deal with
as we've touched on earlier sort of hand
issues wrist issues elbow issues I'm I
mean you saw me when when you guys
arrived today I had myself wrapped up in
this stuff called voodoo floss because I
my elbows are killing me and how have
you seen climbers keep their elbows and
joints in good health because there are
there any particular approaches that you
think have had on I don't think there's
like an easy answer to that kind of
stuff I mean I had some elbow issues for
a while now it's like 8 or 9 years ago
or something but I had sort of like
chronic elbow pain on and off for almost
a year but then eventually it just sort
of resolved and I mean I think the best
way with that kind of stuff is sort of
prevention
you know like made maintain antagonist
muscles and just sort of like stay well
balanced and everything and just and if
you start to feel achy Nisour pain
coming on than to you know take the
appropriate raster or maybe change your
training to some extent basically does
not to let it become a big problem
because I feel like all those overuse
injuries like once they're a problem and
it's like really hard to deal with so
the antagonistic muscles meaning if
you're doing a lot of say like flexor
work kind of gripping that you're going
to use like finger extension and wrist
extension and so on yeah so I've
actually never done the whole extension
stuff with with hands I don't have but
to me antagonist muscles are more like
doing push-ups or random you know or
tricep pulls or things to balance out
your arms a bit ganas you do so much
pulling like to be able to do some kind
of pushing sometimes but what's in your
mind separates a great climber from a
good climber and you can answer that
everyone oh I don't know
I mean yeah I look well again I'll ask
it I'll ask it differently who impresses
you right now as a climb just one of I'm
sure many but just kid marc-andre
Leclerc market andre miller the student
of this canadian guy he's been doing
like all kinds of create the Alpine cell
line which is like wool
and what makes it so crazy I don't know
it just just like kind of blows my mind
a bit and it's funny because I actually
don't ice climb or Alpine climb at a
high enough level to quite understand
what he's doing even like so it's hard
for me to probably appreciate just how
hard it is but then a lot of my friends
who do climb at a very high level or
like whoa that's messed up I'm just like
yeah respek I don't know and for those
people I want to see visuals on this
stuff we'll grab some video and links to
then one of the interesting things with
Mark Andre is that I don't know if
they're like is video Mostel really oh
yeah I mean it's just going out and
doing all this crazy stuff okay you're
just like it's on it's pretty full-on
well I will attempt Jimmy you know this
guy you know of them what what in your
mind makes an impressive as a Alpine
Alpine mr. alpine climber Bob that Jimmy
hasn't even heard any of the stuff he's
like recently been doing in the Rockies
it's like pretty crazy yeah yeah it's
like so crazy I'll repeat for you
guys listen
[Music]
hi Millie oh you know our generation
evolution professional imported next
hotness coming that like jump generation
go ahead anyway he's kind of in that
case to do that people aren't
considering so he's years
so just to try to paraphrase here so his
commitment level is just next-level he
sort of pushing everyone else to
consider things that haven't been done
usually like oh okay and though he does
have a ton of experience really I mean
you know cuz he's just done so much of
it yeah he's been doing mica at any
fruit yeah yeah the commitment level
meeting pushing the envelope is usually
predicated on experience level therefore
you see the some of the older guys doing
it but naughty yeah
because they're all like that's messed
up on the
on the on the danger side this is a
question from Paul Jones so being the
first sponsored Superstar free soloing
do you ever have concerns about the
influence that you can have on young
climbers who may not put in the mileage
in the training to get to a point where
they can do it as safely yeah what are
the two things one I'm definitely not
the first superstar whatever because
they're a bunch of European climbers who
are well known for soloing who've you
know come before me and even in the US
somebody like John backer was like super
well-known in the 1970s and he was on
all kinds of TV programs it might not
have been sponsorship in the same way
that we have today because the industry
wasn't the same but he was definitely on
you know like the evening news and all
kinds of crazy things free soloing so on
I mean I'm definitely not the first by
any means and and it's interesting
because you know I was obviously a kid
who was influenced by that kind of stuff
but then I've gone through you know
years and years of practice or whatever
I kind of feel like soloing is a bit
almost like self-regulating in a way
because the thing is is that anybody can
watch a video and be like I want to do
that but then as soon as they climb 15
or 20 feet off the ground they start to
have a very frank discussion with
themselves like do I really want to do
this you know like it so many feels very
scary because I mean people have like an
overwhelming fear response to the
prospect of falling to their death you
know and so I have an overwhelming peer
response just watching videos well yeah
exactly I mean that's kind of the thing
is that hardly anybody sees that film
it's like oh I'm going to go do that and
then even even if they do once they
start trying to do it I mean it is
actually quite difficult to climb these
walls so it's not as if some kid can
because I wander up and do that and then
and even if they are strong enough or
like you know well versed nuts and
climbing to climb a little bit then
they're also like wow this is really
really scary I didn't expect it to be
this scary and then they just climb back
down no so I mean you know you know I
thought a little bit about influencing
kids and like you know wondering if
that's a bad thing but in general like
you just don't really see copycat things
like you see it a lot more and grab the
assisted sports or like action sports so
like kayaking or skiing or something
where like anyone can just line up at
the top of a cliff and be like I'm going
to hook this cliff I'm going to stick it
it's going to be sick you know and then
once they sort of commit and start going
it's like they're going off the cliff
one way
start the music they can't turn it off
yeah exactly but with climbing it's like
each move that you make upward is like a
decision that you're going to continue
going upward you have to decide over and
over like I want to keep going I want to
keep going I want to keep and a certain
point you're like I don't really want to
keep going like I think Oh to go down
and then you're just like mommy you know
and then like yeah I mean have you ever
hit that point when it was let's just
say or started screaming for mommy
well yeah it's young for mommy or like
hundreds of feet up and you're like I
don't want to keep doing this yeah I
know I've definitely had a bunch of time
so long where I'm like I'm not into this
I'm going down and what happens then
because I've never seen footage of you
climbing down well yeah but that's kind
of a practical thing is if you have
people there filming with you it's like
obviously you're doing something that
you for Hurst or you know a lot about or
it's like a you know it's a classic
enough route that it's worthy to film on
like you have all those epic
misadventures on things that like aren't
that well-known that you know people
aren't climbing all the time but no so
I've had tons of experiences were
especially when I was younger I didn't
really know how to reach out but I love
the little maps that show you like we're
climbing your egos so I'd look at it and
be like okay I think I'm climbing that
big corner and then I go up there and be
like this isn't even the right route
like what the heck am i doing and then
I'd start like questing way to their
left or right being like well maybe if I
traverse 200 feet that way then I'll get
to the real root and then you're like oh
god what am i doing and then it all
starts to go south with you and and then
you'd clen down in an instant slow or I
would like quest over some other route
and escape off Westerners is just a
traverse yeah weird or whatever you know
over there been a couple routes where
I've been like especially I was younger
when I was soloing a route and I get up
and I'll send I'm like oh I'm on a
bolted face but this route isn't
supposed to have bolts and then I'm like
oh no I'm on the wrong route and you
look over and you see that the real
route you're supposed to be on is like
100 meters to the right and then you're
like I wonder what route I'm on and then
you're like oh I hope it's not hard and
then you're something like and then
you start like pulling on the bolts
which is cheating and you're just like
whatever it takes like get off this wall
you know and so you're like pulling on
bolts and stepping on bolts and like
didn't whatever just like get to the top
and then later you're like oh I wish I
knew how to read the guide book
uh now so this is this is a related
question from Drew cordova so there's a
video that shows alex climbing El Cap
free solo where he said he was freaking
out no so that's incorrect well they're
all kinds of in krump sure there's a
video yeah just go on in all of regard
on where he's freaking out on the cliff
face at one point I'd like to know from
his perspective what it takes to
overcome that fear okay so the video
clip that he's referring to I'm actually
free so long in the face of Half Dome
which is a different wall yep
and that's actually complicated because
it shows me standing on this ledge on
Half Dome like having a moment being
really scared but we shot that film like
a year after my actual free solo so I'd
gone up there and soul it about myself
nobody around which is kind of the point
of free soloing normally and then we've
gone back and filmed on any when we
filmed on it I walked out on that ledge
and I had a moment where I was a little
bit afraid and then like sorted myself
out turn around and and climb back but
then they used the voice-over of me
talking about the original experience
when I've actually been free soloing at
the year before where I had like a much
more significant moment on the section
100 feet higher which is actually quite
difficult climbing he's like walking
across the ledge is never that scary you
know I mean like in the grand scheme of
rock climbing like when you're standing
on the ledge like you're not scared it
just happened in that case because I was
standing face out which is like a little
off-balance and a little scary and I was
like whoa this isn't what I expected but
it's not that big a thing but the actual
experience up high it was like one of
the things where they caught this moment
on film and it kind of went well with
the voiceover they're like all perfect
yeah exactly and so it made for a great
film and it definitely like shares the
free solo experience pretty well it's
one of the things at first I was like I
was sort of annoyed that it's not the
literal like this isn't what happened
but the thing is like nobody's there
when it actually happens so then it does
share the experience pretty well so in
the actual Half Dome experience what it
was scary
mmm-hmm even though like you mentioned
earlier you kind of rehearsed what it's
going to feel like as you're going up
this this route what do you what do you
and not to belabor this point but it's
it's something I'm fascinated by what's
going through your head and had was of
that particular Half Dome free solo I
actually hadn't rehearsed it that much
really
I sort of intentionally chosen not to
rehearse the route very much because I
was like oh that's going to take the
adventure out of it I want to just go up
there and do it which in retrospect like
wasn't the best idea
yeah but so yeah on half to him I didn't
I hadn't memorized the sequences I
didn't really know like exactly what I
should do I just knew that I could do it
I knew that I'd gone out there and I'd
done it it was fine and that I was able
to you know in respect I probably should
have spent a little bit more time and so
why I got so scared was I got up to a
certain sequence and I basically like
didn't want to trust a specific foothold
and I was like all this feels like my
foots going to slip and I don't want to
fall and then I tried to use some other
fee but I was like aw this doesn't these
are worse and you know so you're
standing there hesitating being like
what should i do what should I do
and then you start to get all gripped
like oh god what if I can't figure it
out and like you're obviously getting
more and more tired as you stand there
your calves are getting pumped and you
know yeah it's just it's traumatising
all right back back in action so during
a little break we're just talking about
some past lives and bitching that I want
to be a comic book penciler was an
illustrator for period time paying
expenses in college and had this other
weird side gig of bouncing which was
terrible cause I was the smallest guy as
a bouncer but what are the what are the
best and worst jobs that you've that you
had prior to climbing I haven't really
had that many jobs I mean I worked at
the climbing gym as a kid just you know
cleaning the bathrooms and doing summer
camp stuff with kids and then I worked
doing night security at Berkeley for
first semester those there I mean I was
only at Berkeley for a year and so for
my second semester that I was doing ID
security goes but if he's like walking
on campus at night getting paid to like
look at buildings but when you read
Berkeley
how did you decide to leave and what was
that calculus like commune hell yeah I
mean I didn't I didn't decide to just
drop out of Berkeley it was more that I
wasn't really happy there and then my
first year at Berkeley I happened to get
second national at Nationals and so I
got invited to the Youth World Cup which
was during what would have been my
second fall semester and so I decided to
take the semester off and then go to you
know youth worlds and then travel a bit
and climb and do whatever and also my
father happened to die the summer after
freshman year and he was part of the
pressure for like going to school
not really pressure but he just sort of
like expected the kids to go to college
said thing and then when he died it also
left life-insurance money for my sister
and I had to finish school and so you
know that sort of allowed me to not just
not go back to school and so uh yeah and
so just kind of a combination of events
just led me to take the semester off and
then I just like you know I'm just
taking the next kenner not like 20
semesters off since then were you close
your dad I was fairly close to my dad I
mean we weren't super close and like
talking about things and like having
having deep chats but he definitely
invested a ton of time in me you know he
took me to the climbing gym all the time
he would drive me all over the state to
competitions you know he were taking
camping taking outside like you know we
we would be doing family camping trips
in the mountains and stuff so I mean he
definitely put a ton of energy into me
to you and I apologize know your status
do you want to get married have kids
yeah I think I'd like to have a family
someday so that that brings up something
that I wanted to talk about and
hesitated to ask in part because I'm
sure you've been asked a million times
but as it relates to mortality let's
just say that somebody came to you this
was kind of two-in-one they said I have
10 million dollars and I'm going to
dedicate it to you but with the
following condition you have to predict
how you're going to die accurately and
in that case it goes to the cause of
your choosing so what would you predict
and what cause would it go to
um that's interesting and if I predict
wrong it just like doesn't go anymore
disappear spoof okay I don't know I mean
I think I would predict I don't know I'm
sort of 50/50 between natural causes
just like dying of old age at some point
or like climbing accident in the grander
scheme of like not necessarily you know
I falling to my death which is what
people think with the free soloing but
just the random stuff like you know
rappelling in the mountains or like
being swept by an avalanche you're like
being hit by a random rock these there's
a lot of just like random chant or not a
lot but there is random chant chance
involved with climbing and just the fact
that I am out climbing all the time like
you wouldn't be shocking some random
thing just happened to me like that
though I mean that's kind of the you
know price price to play you know like
if you're going to be in those places
like there is just a random random risk
associated with it so yeah I mean I
think and then the cause I would devote
it to I don't know some probably
environment I mean basically the stuff
that I'm supporting through my
foundation which is you know any kind of
environmental projects that like improve
standard of living which has mostly been
like offered solar projects or like
energy access and so for off real solar
and energy axis for for whom or where
who like rural communities I mean I've
been supporting a group that does that
kind of work in Africa which you know
makes sense because folks have no access
to energy and we've also been supporting
grid alternatives here in the States
which does bike home PV systems for like
low-income families basically it's just
a way to like help you know folks that
need some help and a healthy environment
obviously and just we took a break you
were talking about we're talking talking
about books and the fact that you read
mostly nonfiction what nonfiction books
have had a had an impact on you or the
door do you particularly like I mean in
the last several years I mean some of
the most noteworthy books I've read I
guess like a people sister the u.s. the
Howard Zinn book totally changed the way
I look at politics and then in the same
way I read a book recently called sacred
economics that like totally change the
way I looked at economics sacred
economics yeah I was actually totally
understand I forget who the author was
not oh I didn't know I will we will look
it up you should the shona sacred
economics is like kind of Awesome it by
yeah changed my world of it what what's
what are the what's the kind of basic
thesis of security economics or is it I
don't know when the author would say the
pieces but um but the things that I took
away from it were well mean basically
he's sort of envisioning different
systems for like a more just kind of
economics you know because I mean
current our current style of capitalism
basically just concentrates wealth in
the hands of the already wealthy you
know and that's kind of like by
definition the way interest rates work
and stuff like if you have a lot you'll
just continue to make a lot and that's
not a fundamentally fair system because
if you don't have anything you continue
having nothing
but if you already have more than you
need you just get more and more and more
and that's just like not the way the
world should work I don't think or at
least I don't and so one of the ideas
that he throws on the book which found
totally understand was like negative
interest rates so like if you have a lot
it basically just like slowly doing
those Wed unless you're actively using
it for things like investing it into
things so you know just by having a lot
of money is not going to guarantee you
continue to have a lot of money unless
you're allocating it in this yeah that
exactly unless you're using it wisely to
like create value but how do you assess
risk whether that's with and you can you
can focus on one of these but whether
that's on a particular climb on like a
business venture a decision to do a
versus B how do you how do you think
about risk I don't know that's
interesting question because obviously I
spend a ton of time thinking about risk
but I just don't have like a clear-cut
you know like I don't have clear metrics
for like oh you know this is and it
because with the climbing so much if it
comes down to a feeling of like I feel a
lot of fear when I think about that
obviously it's not for me yeah I don't
know exactly and I've never really had
to evaluate business ventures and things
so when let's touch on something you
just said which is if you're very afraid
of something then that's something you
shouldn't do so do you then climb say
hard routes in an absence of fear or is
it present and then you overcome it
that's a good question I generally climb
hard routes in the absence of fear I
generally don't go up on them unless I
feel comfortable and I don't have that
fear yes though yeah though I mean it's
important to sort of differentiate fear
and risk and like all the terms I guess
definitely because you know I mean if
there is a high level of risk I mean you
should be feeling fear I mean fear is
sort of that warning that you know that
there is real danger and so like if
there is danger present like I mean you
should be feeling fear and so you know
and there are times and maybe you should
just suppress that fear and go for it
anyway maybe not I don't know but so
with the free soloing typically if I'm
feeling a lot of fear then
I just you know wait and prepare more or
I don't know some do whatever it takes
to mitigate that to like to feel
comfortable and then and then do the
climb when I feel comfortable and do you
have a nice my suspicion says no but do
you have a checklist like I have to do
this with gear X number of times and
then do this y number of times before
I'm willing to free solo this or is it I
don't have a checklist but I definitely
have a degree of comfort that I need to
feel on the route before I'm willing to
solve it what does that feel like well
just feels like a certain I guess I need
to have a certain amount of reserve I
guess you know I need to feel like I can
climb the route in a variety of
conditions and and have some extra in
the tank just in case you know like if I
can climb the route only by the
narrowest of like razor-thin margins I
mean that's probably not good enough for
free so on and the definitions point is
important so for instance I'm involved
with a lot of speculative startups or
startups whether Spectre all Rebecca
yeah I mean most we would be considered
very highly speculative and people say
wow that's a really high-risk investment
you have a very high risk tolerance and
doing things in entrepreneurship and so
on and I've never felt that way I
actually feel like I'm focused on risk
mitigation at all times i and so for me
I thought about at one point so like all
you have really high risk tolerance risk
risk risk I was like well wait a second
like we should try to figure out the
definition of this term that we're using
before we have a know what isn't the
thing with startups is that you're sort
of willing to lose money on a certain
number as long as exactly some of them
come out right no exactly so I sort of
doing the math on the overall picture
it's like doesn't matter some of them
fail that's exactly right and what's
what's important at least in that game
right is or that sport you can look at
it that way is following your own rules
like if you set rules yeah and you
understand say portfolio theory and the
math if I follow these rules is going to
is going to turn out likely this way
therefore I need to make X number
investments yeah or at least having like
a plan that you're willing to stick to
right and then not start to just get
hog-wild where you're like well this guy
said that and not easy on it yeah
so what I realized for myself that risk
in my mind is the likelihood of an
irreversible negative outcome and if I
look at it that way if I do something
that fails if I can get back to where I
was very easily then that's not a risk
it's not a high risk for instance do you
do you think you relate to risk or think
about it differently than other people
not only all that's pretty much in line
with the way I look at risk I mean yeah
I mean with the startup stuff I wouldn't
consider that particularly risky because
like obviously people make a lot of
money off startups it's just a matter of
like doing it well I mean like you know
playing the stock market and things like
that people obviously make a lot of
money so it's not like a fundamentally
risky activity just a matter of like how
you do it how well you do it and
obviously I'm not in either those worlds
but also I mean for me it probably would
be dangerous because you know I'd be
like well no I have nobody but it's
because that's not my thing like I don't
I don't know anything about it what is
the best decision you've ever made not
to do something or a good decision that
you've made not to do something well I
think pretty much any of the three souls
that are backed off of and climbed down
probably all pretty good decisions I
mean who's to say I mean maybe they all
would have been fine and I would have
just like climb to the top not nice day
but you know there's no point
second-guessing that stuff I mean if you
hike and I was like but I haven't had
any like clear or like near misses where
I decided not to climb something then
there's like a huge avalanche that
sweeps the whole mountain and you're
like thank God I was not there uh you
have very minimalist lifestyle what is
what is something that you spent too
much on but don't regret or something
that you spend too much on but don't
regret or a lot on too much is too
judgmental I don't know I don't think
it's too much but um when I bought
noise-canceling headphones I was like
this seems really indulgent but it made
my life so much better like I love
traveling with noise cancelling
headphones so I got favorite possession
how do you use it I just thought you
know I cancel noise with them yeah do
you use them all the time when you're
traveling or are they like in the
airport and on the plane I pretty much
have noise cancelling headphones on the
whole time I love it I'll just like
listen to soft music and like read my
book or work my computer do whatever you
know just
I just like love not having all the
crazy bustling noise around me the whole
time
what type of music do you listen to most
often when you're flying flying I do a
lot of soundtracks like so it's sort of
like classically type music but you know
set to Indiana Jones but say or whatever
should Braveheart yeah actually I've
never done the paper subject so like
last Mohican - the favorite that's a
great contract I do you ever climb to
music I'll do easy climbing to music for
sure I normally just have my phone in my
pocket and we'll just blast it like you
know stereo so but that's only if I'm
climbing something where there's nobody
around and because I think it's super
annoying when you like hike up to people
on a trail like a boombox going because
obviously it's like dimension their
outdoor experience what do you in this
case is what type of music you listen to
I pretty much only listen like modern
rock like hate rock and stuff like what
I said but like what what yeah what kind
of in I don't know like now I was
looking like Bad Religion oh we listened
Metallica last night on the drive and
like you know I'm a Chevelle or tool or
random whatever what is something that
people and this is in in quotes know
about you that is wrong I mean I think a
lot of people I mean certainly online
commentary a lot of people think I have
a death wish or like have never
experienced fear like just don't don't
care about my safety I mean the thing is
if you just watched youtube videos you
get the impression I just like walk up
to a wall and climb it and like you sort
of miss the 20 years of climbing culture
that's behind it you know the fact that
I've there's a huge history behind all
these roots and I know a lot about them
and I have tons of friends that have
climbed them and I can I could like
recite half the moves on them from
memory you know what I mean like there's
a ton that goes into it the people like
don't see you in a 3 minute YouTube
short and yeah well it's kind of like
you and Laird Laird Hamilton on the
podcast right the sort undisputed king
of big wave surfing people would it's
funny how people look at that and they
have a different judgment than when they
look at you on a wall even though in
practical terms you think I mean don't
people look at his big white surf and be
like that guy's crazy he has a death
wish well because I kind of do for my
best over my so I think that it's
slightly the
the frequency with which I hear people
say that is different because they look
at a wall and they're like oh I could
climb up things but they look at a
hundred foot wave and somebody getting
towed in on a jetski and they're like I
wouldn't even be able to stand up on the
board while getting pulled on jetski
therefore assumption assumption
assumption would you think of say free
divers to try to break records in free
diving
I mean I don't know much about it but it
does seem like it's one of the riskiest
sports in the world
I mean more people die doing that than
virtually anything else yeah I mean it
kind of goes with wingsuiting or
something we're like you know it's fair
to say that it actually is quite risky
because people do actually die all the
time doing it have you ever done lucid
stuff no I did my FF so I like learned
how to parachute out of a client on the
thought that I would maybe eventually
learn how to base jump or something and
then I was basically like I'm not into
this I'm like I don't think this is cool
I don't like it just the just because
the risk the downside was no I mean oh
that's do that um no skydiving is not
dangerous you know so I mean when you're
learning out of the plane like it's not
sketchy at all but mostly I was like I
just don't like this you know and like I
don't want to devote the energy to like
learning how to do this and I sort of
realized how much it would take for me
to to feel comfortable doing that I was
like this is just on loan not to do it
yeah and then as it turns out you know
like one of my good friend the climbing
partners died wingsuiting and then last
year notably Dean Potter died
wingsuiting and so I mean you know
climbing has lost a lot of high end
climbers to including accidents it's
like yeah I mean it is a very dangerous
activity imagine Dean Potter useless it
I mean I think when I hear his name I
also associated with an expose liner
exactly slap I you seem to have the
perfect slacklining feet I'd odd me
maybe taking a photograph they're almost
over
yeah that's amazing like functional feet
and you slackline marginal that's the
very kind way it sort of deformed oh
yeah highly functional yes do you select
do slackline or what's your PIN like
slackline is like a low level you know I
can like walk blindsiding for it's just
because there's so many slack lines and
campgrounds and climbing areas and
things you know I definitely have done a
fair amount of psyche lining and I can
do some like really easy tricks and
things but but no I'm definitely not a
slackline and I've never done any high
lines and I'm not like not in this like
lining when you think of the word
success
is the first person who comes to mind
for you when I hear successful yeah just
the word successful I mean when you just
set it up at Elon Musk but that like I
have no idea because I don't know but I
don't know that much about business I'm
just like that thread is there uh is
there any one that you would want to
model your life after in any way um
probably not
but so I do like reading you know
biography or something and then sort of
like I have some notes on my phone of
like lists from random things I've read
you know where you sort of choose little
lessons out of like a book about
somebody you're like oh like that person
did these things well and those are all
things that I could apply to my life but
you know I wouldn't want to model my
whole life I'm somebody that's more like
you know cherry-pick hearing good
lessons here and there uh which
biographies have produced a lot of notes
for you I was just a few times but so I
read on the biography of a Brad Washburn
who was like a big if you know him he
was like a mouseka Explorer photographer
he also ran those like a Natural History
Museum in Boston I think but so he just
had like a wide and varied career and he
was like a National Geographic Explorer
type you know he just did a lot with his
life and so after I finished reading the
book I was like whoa this guy like got
done you know and I don't you know
I respect that and so I just like kind
of thought about it what is something
you believe that other people think is
crazy that I believe that other people
think is crazy
why don't I mean I think that my
evaluation of risk and all the things we
were just talking about a lot of people
think it's totally crazy but that's
because I mean I think it's because they
don't have a full set of facts on it you
know they don't quite appreciate it in
the same way that I do but I don't know
if I have any other like totally
outlandish beliefs like that do you uh
I'm sure you've had this question before
but would you consider yourself a
religious person give
particular belief system now I'm like
strongly atheist and just like not into
religion at all we're your parents
religious at all and yeah mom is it be
used to identify as Catholic as she'd
probably still say that she believes in
God though there's no evidence of it at
all you know like she doesn't go to
church anymore do anything but um yeah
so as kids we were taken to church but
at no point did I ever believe anything
okay so there was no sort of
transitionary period of us no I know a
one it's funny like even though we were
being taken to church I just always
thought it was all a bunch of weird
stories you're just like it made no
sense to me like why would you believe
in some invisible thing that you know
I'm like like why would you ever believe
any of that like it doesn't make any
sense it's weird because weird that so
many bad ult's believe all that stuff
cuz it still doesn't make any sense
there's a lot of stuff that doesn't make
a lot of sense that people believe to
you know theater politics and else or to
our offer but I this is going to be a
gear shift I mean that I made a lot of
years I'm grinding out the transmission
of gears but of food I want to talk
about give any particular thoughts on
food or how do you think about eating
yourself oh not literally eating
yourself yeah yeah I mean I'm not much
of a cook and I don't like love food or
food prep or anything you know I mean if
I could I would just like take a pill
and be like fully fully fed all day
every day and just like sweet I don't
have to worry about it but um I don't
know I mean in the last couple years
I've gone vegetarian which has more to
do with all like the environmental
nonfiction I've been reading it some
more just as like one of the few things
I can do as an individual till I really
have an impact on the world but ya know
I mean give any give any go to dinner so
what are your most common dinners what
do they look like I mean for all the
years that I've lived in the van one of
my go to dinners was like mac and cheese
with with stuff in it you know like
adding a vegetable yeast add tuna to it
a lot of then I've switched just like
vegetables or you know maybe some beans
or whatever you're like mac and cheese
and chili so now I'm sort of easing away
from mac and cheese too so I kind of
stopped eating dairy but so like you
know rice and vegetable stuff or
like lentils or whatever keeping it
simple yeah
so many questions so many questions I
want to ask give any morning rituals
like what are the first 60 days 60 days
first 60 minutes of your day look like
very much always just get up and have
like a big breakfast and then go
climbing that's kind of the standard
when is though like it for the last two
months I've been waking up doing some 15
minutes of stretching then eating my
breakfast then going climbing just to go
to the back stuff but what time do you
generally wake up and go to bed
I generally I'm pretty unstructured so I
basically just go to sleep whenever I'm
whenever I need to or whenever make
sense and I just wake up whenever I try
to sleep as much as I want to what is
that basically in that I mean I people
think they're like all that 4-hour
workweek guys like I'm asleep 3 hours a
night I try to sleep 8 to 10 ya know I'm
all about day to 10:00 for sure I think
last night I mean I was sleeping in
front of your house was my biggest Lesha
I think I slept nine last night well be
okay with you second that the damn yeah
that's my heart
just walking my dog and I was like who's
camped out in front of my house and I
was hilarious okay yeah with
like the reflectors of the way I was
like who is and I'm trying to kidnap me
we don't know that's my rape leg
infarction for your host was it's one of
the things like we drove to San
Francisco last night and then I'm like
well I don't want to park somewhere else
and have to drive here in the morning so
I'm like I'm just gonna go park there
I'm gonna sleep as late as possible and
wake up I'm gonna come in and do
progress I'm not totally shown it from
for what that's the thing about living
in the car is you're all about like
minimizing the waste of time you know
there's no point like driving around in
circles you just park where you need to
be sleep and then do you think that's
amazing alright and if I is after and
I've lived in a van for like ten years
now you know it starts to become a
routine it's like hard to imagine like
going to a hotel moving all your
into a room moving it back into your car
later moving the car you're just like
what a waste of time I just want to like
park where I need to be so a lot of
people have asked this and I'm kind of
curious myself like the logistics of
Alex Honnold so if you have a date date
goes well what then to come back to the
van
I mean it's a nice man it's like a you
call it a little mini home or whatever
you know what a micro home stuff
radicals
yes just turning on books editor you see
I have one out front yeah uh-huh
you said now before you go out on the
day be like just in case this goes well
you put out like like like some rose
petals in a bowl of water or like
perfectly go back to their place a
little classier do you have any favorite
documentaries and movies
oh not particularly I guess I mean my
movie taste runs or just straight like a
Hollywood action movie like total fluff
you know like gladiator or something
just like fun times like yeah Roger all
right we'll keep that it's all pretty
yeah it's always pretty like
unimpressive but it's kind of because
like movies because I do a lot of like
reading nonfiction and stuff I feel like
movies filter floss category you know
like I hate heavy nonfiction
like heavy documentary type sounds I
just like fall asleep though it's too
much thinking at the intersection
computing what movies have you seen the
greatest number of times so anything
you've watched like over and over again
I have that habit I've probably seen the
Star Wars movies a lot a lot of times
but that's partially just because I
started around as a kid and have like
rewash them over the years I don't know
if I've seen anything else like more
than that probably I think I have maybe
weird numbers because for each of my
books I get very I feel very isolated if
I'm writing at night in a dark house by
myself so I was put on certain movies I
have movies for each book they're
usually one or two movies that I'll just
put on repeat and I'll put them on mute
and then listen to music like the same
tracks over and over and over and over
again your brain might be like hardwired
some weird way through well I got it
that's definitely true but I shouldn't
week I got a signed favor like I had a
recommendation from this very very very
brilliant and capable entrepreneur named
Matt Mullenweg who's of great coder and
he always he listens to the same single
track over and over again almost like a
noise machine when he's coding
and I thought okay well I'll try that
with writing and it worked really really
well but the movies end up being really
weird because if there were movies or
guitars so well for the 4-hour workweek
it was the
that where that think these are fine
movies but the Bourne Identity mmm was
the first and then for the for our body
it was Casino Royale which i think is a
coherence they like rocky or something
so being non-stop training montages
there's a lot of fight scenes and the
parkour sequence in the beginning with
yes yeah yeah yeah so that's yeah
separate I didn't know that was uh yeah
so cool and then for the 4-hour chef the
this is super this is the off theme
completely but I was just looking for a
movie when I was just getting started
and on Amazon Prime the first movie that
popped up was babe lunatic
yeah farmer Hoggett Eggman I want time
like a thousand times so I just put on
repeat watch it like four or five times
a night
whoa go figure yeah we could
psychoanalyze that hardcore hardcore
aside from the noise canceling
headphones what purchase has most
positively impacted your life in the
last say I mean six months
definitely my van definitely event yeah
I mean no question yeah I mean the last
man that you know I bought a ten
thousand dollar van and lived in it for
ten years and then this new van that I
bought it's the new van so it's
obviously a bit pricier but it's like
pretty awesome I'll probably live in
there for another ten years
well maybe not actually live in it but
you know be based out of it uh again
returning to the this is this is not
directly related to the dating in the
van but this is this is a question for
Michael
Cipriano I've always found climbing to
have a large positive effect on my
libido do you this attics find this to
be the case who have climbed for my
entire life so I mean maybe it explains
permanent I believe is that for real
that's a real question I guess I guess I
don't know I mean that's probably true
of anybody who's like staying active and
staying fit you know you're just like
the way your body supposed to work
yeah are there ways that you've seen
lessons learned or skills developed and
climbing translate to other parts of
your life and if so does any any
particular examples come to mind
um
I don't know examined a lot from being a
professional climber like having to go
and give talks and like do the whole
work side of climbing and that's really
like helped me grow the person and feel
comfortable doing public speaking and
all that kind of stuff so I think from
the actual climbing itself maybe the
most useful thing I've gotten has been
sort of being able to differentiate you
know risk and consequence and fear and
like all these different things and sort
of being able to separate my feelings
from what's actually happening you know
like oh I feel fear but is that your
justified because I'm actually in danger
or is that like totally irrational fear
that I should just squish and like move
forward with something and I don't know
I mean I feel like climbing is sort of
helped me understand like the different
things that are going on there you know
where I feel like a lot of people just
like oh I'm afraid and then there's like
oh god I'm afraid you know but sometimes
like I mean fear shouldn't necessarily
control you any more than anything else
you know desire or fill in the blank
yeah I'm not like you know when you're
really hungry you know like oh god I'm
hungry I'm hungry I'm hungry they're
just like oh I'll eat lunch in two hours
you know I feel like fear to some extent
should be the same way where you can
just register like oh I'm feeling fear
right now but sometimes that doesn't
matter
I mean sometimes it doesn't need to be
like oh you know I'm about to die like I
should watch out for that but but a lot
of times I mean you should be able to
just set that for your side and just do
exactly what you're supposed to be doing
yeah so I made in a way when you're kind
of sore fear I mean you can distinguish
so the varietals yeah and yeah when you
experience enough fear in your life
you're like oh now I can sort of
differentiate between all the different
types do you drink coffee or caffeine no
though I don't have I just don't like
coffee
and I don't really like tea and but I
don't have any problem with caffeine I
don't really even notice caffeine I
don't think that much because you get it
in my shop locks and gels and goos and
whatever all the little energy products
like some of them are caffeine and some
dough and I don't feel like I noticed an
effect either way the reason I asked is
that I find personally I remember I did
a three-day meditation retreat my first
meditation retreat and they disallowed
caffeine
I said no caffeine and no alarm clocks
you wake up when you wake up and when I
close in my life I'm on another 20-year
meditation
yeah I need to do more of that and I
came back from that experience and went
back into my normal routine which was
drinking coffee at that point but a lot
of iced tea like I go to a restaurant
they just endlessly refill my iced tea
and I felt like a complete crackhead
like a misery of crack and I was like is
this what my normal was holy and
the reason that I brought it up is that
it strikes me that at least in that
state I would have a lot of trouble
distinguishing the fine nuances of
different types of because you're just
overwhelming you're all jacked up on
sugar form I see stuff and then you're
again like caffeine who knows yeah
totally there's like a lot going on too
geologically and it's hard to
differentiate like what the what the
finer points are yea the signal from the
noise at what climbing grades have you
plateaued the most this is from Liz
Wolfe and she just said 511 plateau has
been really bad for me which probably
means she hasn't got past the 511 Blanca
Excel which was like mired in 511 mind
no so I basically I pretty much
progressed steadily to about mid 514 so
like 14 B or C and I've basically been
plateau there for like 7 or 10 years or
something so I feel like I've sort of
plateaued there because I'm at the point
I mean because mid 514 is definitely a
fairly high level of climbing though
it's by no means elite by the world
standard anymore
like that's not that's not like super
hard just put in perspective what it
would be a little artist thing in the
world of 15 C but only two people have
climbed that but there are a lot of
people climbing like 15a and 15b ish now
and so climbing like 14 B or C is like
you know respectable but a lot of people
can do that like first try no problem
not a lot but a handful of people can
climb that first try no problem it's
like trivial for them so you know I mean
it's not it's by no means world standard
but you know it's it's solid but so I
think that for me that's sort of my
natural plateau like that's kind of what
I can climb without having to train much
to climb harder you know because the
thing is I spend a lot of my year doing
like adventure trips and expeditions and
you know doing stuff through my
foundation and going to Angola last year
I mean trips like that that do not help
your fitness at all like they won't help
you climb harder but they definitely
make you a more well-rounded climber
probably a better person and more
interesting you do fun stuff and so you
know I've sort of been content being
plateaued at mid 514 for a long time so
I could see at some point in my life I
might devote a year to like actually
trying to climb hard because I'd love to
climb the the French grade nine a which
is 14 D and us grades it's just sort of
like a meaningful benchmark grade that
if I work on 9a I'd be like respect like
I'm good like that's that's hard enough
for me so if you wanted to do that hard
climbing what would the most important
components of that training look like
I'm not totally sure I mean I think for
me it would require more finger boarding
or hang boarding like basically just
focusing more on finger strength because
I think as a climber that's probably
what I'm worst at is just like the pure
strength holding onto things but also I
think for me would just require more
dedicated focused the hard climbing for
the year you know like right now I'm
climbing in Yosemite and in my whole
season of climbing you cemani I won't do
a single hard move basically at the you
know at the physical limit of like what
I can actually pull on because I'm
climbing these like great big walls and
I'm trying to climb it quickly and
sometimes I'm climbing the rope list but
anyway I'm doing them in Aldie styles it
like just doesn't help you pull harder
and so like if I wanted to climb harder
grades I would have to just pull harder
if you could no longer climb but had to
pick a physical activity what would you
pick if I couldn't climb I don't know I
have a lot of respect for ultra runners
I think because they sort of interact
with the landscape in the same way that
I kind of like to you know like the
something like the ultra - or mob wall
when you like run all the way around the
mall all messy I mean that's pretty cool
I'm like I would love to be able to do
things like that but I just like don't
really I can't run that well but but the
thing is is that I really love running
like mountain ridge lines and things and
the night quickly becomes actual rock
climbing and so I'm like well it's like
I don't know but yeah ultra running is
pretty awesome or I don't know I could
be into like big mountain skiing too I
same but see it all sort of gravitates
back to its mountains and I'm like well
that's basically climbing well then you
get exposed to nasty things like
avalanches for those of you haven't seen
Mara Jesus Jimmy both of you guys make
me sweat not that I need any help I tend
to run hot drinking tea anyway but
okay hi Gress as usual
what do you world class at aside from
climbing or within climbing that people
might not realize or how would your best
friends answer that question I don't
know I mean I guess one with in climbing
I'd say that is it because I'm known as
the free soloist I'm known for the rope
was climbing and that's like what you'll
see online and you know all the videos
and all that but I'd probably still be a
professional climber even if I didn't
free solo at all like right now I hope
the speed record I'm like pretty much
every major formation you so many but
you know all the different phases like
all the classic grooves like I mean I
think that's basically true and so yeah
and I mean I'd probably still be like
one of the more well rounded climbers in
America even without the free soloing
but um but it's all sort of overshadowed
by the like oh my god is robles and it's
funny because I only do you know a
handful of solos a year if that and then
I spend the whole rest of the year
climbing with partners and ropes and
like normal climbing with my friends
just like doing all kinds of interesting
things and expeditions and whatever and
yet it still just comes down to like
whoa free soloing but you know that I'm
fine with that because at least I could
do a climb all the time what advice
would you give to 25 year old self 25 or
20 depending on who needed it the most
and if you could just place like what
you were doing where you were at the
time well 20 is still slightly too old
but like my 18 year old self I'll just
tell I would say it does not bother
going to college at all because like the
year that I spent at Berklee was the
total waste went on basically not not
because there's anything wrong with
Berkeley but because I just wasn't
passionate about what I was studying and
there's no that there was no point me
like grinding out of your studies that I
didn't care about that you know I should
have just like gone caught me because I
mean that's what I really cared about
and that's what's been so funny over the
years is it like with climbing you know
I have no problem putting in you know 20
to 40 hours a week every week all year
in de climbing like and I mean that's
the theremin keeping a training Journal
so I have like sort of hours of exercise
and last year
I counted up at the end of it at the new
year and I basically averaged like 27
hours a week of exercise every week last
year which is you know like I think
that's kind of comparable to others I
mean you would know more than me but
other sports like for training volume
but I mean then when you think that I've
probably been doing that for the last
ten years I've been on the road and
actually and last year was a
particularly low volume year for me
because I had a book come out so I did a
month of October and I also did like a
month of tour in South America and so
like I was climbing much less than I
normally would so presumably a few years
ago living in the van I was probably
doing like 30 probably 30 or 32 hours a
week of exercise which is like a lot of
time spent climbing there's a lot of
time but what else you can put in your
training drill what other details are in
there it's one line I do one-line hours
of exercise one line any additional like
strength training type stuff for like
the stretching on the noon recently and
then one mind diet which is like eight
well a poorly eight so-so or like you
know too many cookies like whatever
things like that do you go back doodle
of cookies sometimes of an unfortunate
what's your go-to cookie which I just
talked to cookies like straight I can
eat a lot of cookies yeah well that's
probably the only thing that Letta CLE
was not like that we share in common so
yeah you do yeah they're looking towards
you're tall well I was looking at others
like secret stash I have to keep it out
of sight yeah there are these chocolate
chip cookies that are actually from Long
Island Tate's I think there is adding
are they're imported chocolate soup Wow
originally from Long Island and they
have there's their chocolate chip
cookies in there these I think they're
gluten free ginger cookies and I can't
have those in my house or I demolished
that's my thing like Suze I don't really
buy this very much because about by it I
just eat it all immediately like I'm
terrible with moderation so I generally
don't have any dessert in the van and I
want to do I just eat it all if you were
to I know this is this is a bit of a
reach but you're 30 now let's say your
idealized forty year old self right what
advice do you think that forty year old
would give you now
I don't know I mean I feel like I'm
doing pretty well right now
oh I'm not saying you're not uh yeah no
I don't know I mean just you know just
enjoy the ride yeah just enjoy the
process what would you like your life to
look like in ten years
and I mean maybe have a family or
something or at least like a solid
partner solid something going on I think
I'd like to maybe own a home or like
have have a place that I'm kind of
living like more of a solid home base
just because like living in a van is
great but you know at a certain point
you're like man it's nice to have like a
bathroom but I'm having like a shower of
things so how do you deal with that
actually now that I know that it because
that's why when I came into your house I
use your bathroom
oh that's gonna it was like lot so like
last night you're like oh man a too much
water I have no I have a pee bottle I
mean you know I've used a bottle for
ever and actually thing is when you get
used to using a people all the time like
when I pull into a grocery store or
something I would just like pee in my
bottle before I go in you know because
you're like why would I ever go and find
some like dank public bathroom when like
I can just use my bottle it's like well
you guys do you have is it a disposable
pee bottle like a no no ever like I use
a Nalgene now I use like a two liter
bottle just like some random plastic
bottle and I basically use it over and
over until it's like this is repulsive
and then I recycle it and I move on to
another but it's actually kind of the
distal it's like an have the natural
life cycle because I'll use the same
water bottle for climbing it'll just be
like some random two-liter bottle that's
in my bag for like months but then
eventually it starts to get disgusting
or just kind of you know a little gross
and so then I'm like well that becomes a
pee bottle and then I get another bottle
it's like the four month cycle on my
bottles you know do you label them or do
you know my key level
yeah with a pee bottle you just know
like you know when you open the bottle
you're like oh I shouldn't drink this
but also I have systems with like where
things go you know I'm never going to
accidentally like drink my people do you
had do people visit you in your van like
hang out in your van the size of the
days yeah no I mean friends hang out my
van for sure I mean a lot of my climbing
friends would be staying in a tent
normally or staying wherever so I mean
for them it's a big step up to hang out
in the van it's like climate controlled
you know you can it's like sheltered you
can cook
on my stove it's lit I mean it's a nice
place to hang out in evenings if you
could have one billboard with anything
on it what would it say or what would
you put on it get a message to the world
oh I don't know I mean the page it's
just like I don't know environmental
propaganda or something or like the
meter I'm like pretty stoked on all the
vegetarian type of stuff now just
because it's such an easy way to
minimize your impact on the planet and
it's just you know that I mean it just
solves so many different environmental
issues but I don't know but the thing is
a billboard is not the best way to say
don't eat meat because it's like it's
obviously a lot more complicated in that
nobody's going to read that and be like
okay I'll stop right you know it's like
request requires more of a conversation
yeah I mean it requires like a whole and
even then it's like it's not in to say
that like meat is fundamentally bad it's
like how you get it where it's from what
you're supporting I mean you know it's
like a whole feedlot versus this vs.
yeah yeah I mean even that's like really
complicated yeah because there are
places in the world where it makes sense
to raise animals because like you can't
raise anything else you can't grow crops
you know yeah whatever and so what have
you changed your mind about in the last
few years if anything I mean the first
thing that comes to mind is like in high
school I was reading a bunch of iron
Randor and Rand whatever you know like
Objectivist all super black and white
basically like f the poor people should
work harder they should try harder and
now as a 30 year old I'm basically like
all about trying to help the poor trying
to help the plan in different ways
trying to make the world a better place
it's like full 180 from you know the
black and white that I was into in high
school and then yeah I mean I've had
massive changes on all those kinds of
things I mean I used to be way more
harsh you know and like my political
views are like way further less now I'm
just way more I mean I'm a lot more
compassionate now I feel like those
twenty not so much on a personal level
because I don't really here put on like
a societal level of a lot more
compassionate that's a good place yeah I
can't let that one go right away so
because I was like I can't
self-described as compassionate because
none of my friends would agree you know
because the thing is about like nice to
like bye
shredder unlike a one-on-one level not
like a super kind person I don't big but
um but definitely in the grander sense I
mean I'm trying to make I'm I aspire to
make the world a better place and make
it more more just world you know on the
macro level yeah exactly
so in high okay so if I took sake a
couple of your closest friends and gave
them a bottle or two a wine or just
hanging out how would they describe you
I don't know I mean if you ever get in
the instead of the Vic well I mean think
I'm pretty Frank I think and so people
can you know think I can kind of be a
dick sometimes and though I just
consider that being very honest you know
you keep it real yeah I'm just keeping
it real keep it real I mean I'd like to
think that my friends would still call
me a good person you know that I'm still
like still trying to I'm doing my best
you know
gives any we're going to wrap up here
any ask or request for my audience that
could be something you want them to
think about something you would like
them to try something like them to do I
feel like they're all MMA fighters I
don't know ass and not to beat me up
over there not all MMA fighters I assure
you I'm gonna do something positive in
the world of film okay
not a bad place to wrap up where can
people find more of you online best
place to say hello see what you're up to
um I mean my most personal outlet is
probably my Facebook fan page I'm like
constantly posting stuff that I care
about and it's all managed by me and so
it's just like me posting articles that
I think are interesting it's kind of
like a combination of the climbing stuff
that I'm into and then like the
environmental stuff that I'm into
basically I post the environmental stuff
is all the stuff I care about and I post
just enough climbing so everyone doesn't
leave and is that what was the URL so
that not those Cheerios or calm slash
Alex Honnold I think okay but if you
just search search for it it's you know
like a fan page it's like several
hundred thousand people or whatever
hom n o LD yeah well Alex I really
appreciate you taking the time I've been
hoping to me for a long time given that
we're not that far apart oftentimes with
Yosemite so its president this is a this
has been fun and was like once I fix my
elbows maybe I'll see if I can attack
there you should be zero
and maybe actually get outdoors which I
would enjoy all right so I will
hopefully do more than a three day
meditation retreat given that you been
doing it for twenty years they might
extend my ambition a little bit but
thanks very much every other said no
thanks or having pleasure and everybody
listening for show notes links to
everything that we talked about please
just go to 4-hour workweek com forward
slash podcast and until next time as
always thank you for listening
[Music]
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is 508 Friday do you want to
get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email for me every
Friday event provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and 500 Friday's
a very short email where I share the
coolest things I found or that I've been
pondering over the week that could
include favorite new albums that have
discovered it could include gizmos and
gadgets and all sorts of weird that
have somehow dug up in the the world of
the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
headspace more than 80% of the people I
have interviewed world-class performers
across the military entertainment sports
and beyond all have some type of
meditative practice I tried for years
and years and failed miserably the key
is making it simple and you can
dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help
you this change comes through guided
meditation and headspace is by far the
most popular app for this purpose more
than 4 million users it's meditation
made simple so what I recommend is that
you take this practice meditation which
is rooted in thousands of years of
tradition supported by thousands of
scientific studies and try it for 10
minutes a day for 10 days that's all you
need to do you could also check out the
founder and II put it combs head talk
which has more than 5.5 million views
his last name is pu d bi c om b e if you
want to look that up but otherwise
download the free headspace app I have
it on my phone and begin there take 10
program for 10 days of guided meditation
completely free 10 minutes a day that's
all it takes you should give it a shot
headspace calm forward / Tim just go to
headspace calm forward / Tim
this episode is brought to you by
99designs when your business needs a
logo website business card thumbnail or
any other design I recommend checking
out 99 designs I use them myself I've
used them for many years I used them to
create book cover prototypes for the
4-hour body which went on to becoming
number one York Times bestseller I've
also used them for banner ads
illustrations and much more with 99
designs you get a variety of original
designs from designers around the world
give your feedback and then pick your
favorite your happiness is guaranteed so
check out some of my competitions and
designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss show
listeners at 99 designs com forward
slash Tim and right now you can get a
free 9 million dollar upgrade on your
first design so check it out 99 designs
com forward slash temp and until next
time thank you for listening
[Music]
[Applause]